hello and welcome to safety Ridge on
Sunday it's three days before the budget
we've got the chancellor and the shadow
Chancellor on the program a week ago I
thought I knew exactly how this program
would go but that's before a tweet by
Gary lineker turned into a full-blown
existential crisis for the BBC the match
of the day presenter was taken off air
for breaching impartiality guidelines
prompting a mass walkout by other staff
what the director General has apologized
to viewers but he is under pressure to
solve a crisis that snowballed in a
matter of days and don't worry there
will also be plenty of budget coverage
on the show today as well
in a moment we will hear from the
chancellor Jeremy Hunt ahead of his big
speech on Wednesday
we'll also get reaction from labor with
the shadow Chancellor Rachel Reeves
also this morning someone who knows a
thing or two about writing budget
speeches the former Chancellor Lord
Hammonds
and we'll talk to the former England
teammate of Gary lineker John Barnes as
that BBC impartiality route spirals and
we'll also be joined on the show this
morning by the SMP leadership candidate
Ash Regan that's ahead of tomorrow
night's big live TV debate on Sky News
[Music]
foreign
good morning well it's a big week in
British politics with a budget on
Wednesday let's crack straight on shall
we we can hear from the chancellor
thank you very much for being on the
program good morning Sophie good morning
now I appreciate it might feel slightly
strange starting a pre-budget interview
talking about tweets from Gary lineker
but it has spiraled into a foreground
crisis for the BBC do you think he needs
to apologize
well I personally profoundly disagree
with the comments that he made but I
think what this shows and indeed the
related debate about the BBC Chairman's
appointment and we should wait until the
investigation is completely independent
investigation before passing judgment on
that
is that impartiality at the BBC is
really important the reason that it is a
great National Institution that we all
treasure so much is because it is
respected for impartiality so we need to
make sure that what comes out of this is
that people's confidence in the
impartiality of the BBC is restored so
you think that it's been compromised by
no and I don't think it's for me I'm one
of the people by the way who the BBC
scrutinize
um and as do you in in your show and so
it's not for me to tell the BBC how to
do that but I think what this has shown
is how important the BBC is to all of us
and the central thing that people want
to know is that you know there isn't any
kind of political agenda in the way the
BBC goes about its business which I'm
not saying there is
but that is the confidence people need
to have but that's the point isn't it
because you talk about the confidence
and impartiality but I can't help
wondering if what we've seen has led
people to question the BBC's
Independence which is also very
important as well you mentioned of
course Richard Sharp the chairman of the
BBC who found to declare his role in
facilitating an 800 000 pound loan to
Boris Johnson you say that you want to
keep out of the Gary lineker debate and
it's for the BBC but we're only in this
position because MPS like yourself
swella bravaman Robert generic other
conservative Adventures have come out
very strongly to criticize Gary Lincoln
treat and now you're just trying to wash
your hands of it well I think that BBC
and Independence really does matter for
the country and that's why I think it's
important that we let the BBC sort out
these problems but what I want to see is
the outcome is trust be maintained in
what is a very very important
institution when it comes to an election
we are very lucky to be in a country
where we have an organization that is an
independent Arbiter of the truth so that
people can find out the facts and then
make their judgment about which party to
vote for that's something very precious
do you think that's what we want to make
sure that we protect do you think the
current BBC leadership is seen as too
close to the party of government well I
don't think it's for me to make those
judgments I think that if we believe the
BBC should be independent which I do if
we believe in BBC and partiality which I
do then we have to let the BBC resolve
these issues I guess one of the reasons
people feel strongly about impartiality
is because Gary lineker has paid an
awful lot of taxpayers money
do you think that the funding model of
the BBC should be looked at
well I think we always need to keep up
with the times and you know we're in a
world where funding models for all
broadcasting is changing with you know
the Advent of streaming for example
um but do I believe in a taxpayer-funded
broadcaster uh that is able to
for example be one of the most respected
news gatherers in the world yes I do I
think it's very important for the
country and actually very important for
the world so I think we have something
very precious with the BBC that's why
we're we're talking about it even though
you're a competitor of the bbcs because
it's very important to all of us and I
think what we want to come out of this
is people feeling confident that the BBC
is on the right track when it comes to
Independence impartiality all these
things that really matter well if all
that matters you previously said that
Gary lineker should apologize do you
still think that well I don't agree with
his comments then uh you know I
personally think that he was wrong to
say what he said but I don't think it's
for me to decide
as I say I I don't agree with what he
said I I as a government we want to get
on with solving uh the issue of illegal
migration partly because I'm very proud
we're one of the most open and tolerant
countries in the world when it comes to
Legal migration but if you believe in
BBC Independence then it's not for the
chancellor or any other government
minister to say how these issues are
resolved going back then from the call
for the apology it feels like
um now I don't want to waste time
rattling through a list of possible
measures that might be in the budget you
telling me you can't talk about them
frustrating for me frustrating for you
frustrating for our viewers as well so
what in Broad terms should we expect
from your budget well I am a
conservative who believes in the virtue
of work
I am incredibly proud of the fact that
because we've reduced taxes on the
lowest paid change the welfare system
introduce the national living wage
someone who is on benefit and out of
work
will make an extra seven and a half to
ten thousand pounds if they get a job
full time on the national living wage
and that's one of the reasons why
unemployment has halved since we've been
in power but we still have over a
million vacancies in the economy and the
brexit decision was a choice the right
choice in my judgment to say we
shouldn't fill those vacancies from
unlimited migration we need to break
down the barriers that stop people here
in the UK from working whether that's
parents who have obstacles because of
child care costs whether it's older
people who feel they need to retire
earlier than they might perhaps want to
whether it's long-term sick who find
there are barriers to working we need to
break down those barriers and this is a
budget in which I will be systematically
going through all the areas where there
are barriers that stop people working
who want to so that we can help people
get back to work fill those vacancies
for our business the problem is is quite
hard to get people back to work if they
don't have to isn't it if you're taking
an early retirement and you can afford
to do it why would you leave the golf
course and go back to work and also I
understand that there are real barriers
for some parents going back to work many
people it's a choice that they want to
spend more time with the young family
surely the easiest way to fill those
vacancies if we're real is by
immigration well I think our choice is
not to do that why not um because that
was the decision in the brexit
referendum
control over borders and you could
decide to relax certain immigration
rules to fill certain vacancies can you
controlled legal migration but not
filling every vacancy in our businesses
with uncontrolled migration and that was
the decision we took by leaving the
single Market
we fully respect the choice of people
who don't wish to work this isn't about
changing that choice but there are lots
of people let me give you an example
there are 700 000 parents online pay on
Universal Credit who have a child Under
12 and they aren't able to work because
of the high cost of child care now we're
looking at whether we can remove some of
those barriers for example by paying
them their child care in advance not in
arrears looking at the level of support
that we give them and those are families
that would really benefit if the mum or
the day I was able to get back into work
that's removing a barrier that's
stopping people participating in the
labor force I think that's a good thing
some people on your own side are getting
a bit Twitchy about the level of
Taxation shall we say Corporation taxes
due to rise from 19 to 25 when you ran
to be party leader this is what you told
me on corporation tax you said I'm also
someone who doesn't think we shouldn't
just stop the corporation tax Rises I
think we should cut them so that the
lowest in Europe and North America I
think we should cut it to 15 are you
really going to be the chancellor who
puts it up to 25 what happened to that
Jeremy Hunt well it's the same Jeremy
Hunt that's with you now and I still
want us to have the most competitive
business taxes anywhere in the world
look I am a conservative who believes in
a low tax economy I'm incredibly proud
of the fact that under successive
conservative governments we've reduced
taxes so that for the first time in our
history you can earn a thousand pounds a
month without paying a penny of tax or
National Insurance that's by the way
that is one of the reasons why we've
lifted 2 million people out of absolute
poverty after housing after housing
costs that's including half a million
children so it's a it's a very very big
deal that we've done that for businesses
we need to encourage investment
investment by companies from overseas
coming into the UK investment by
companies at home that's how we'll close
our productivity Gap but I also have to
be responsible with public finances
we're not going to do what the last
Labor government did and run out of
money businesses need the stability that
comes from being responsible so we will
get there gradually there we will but
let's look at the tax level shall we
because if you look at the current tax
burden you can see here it's projected
to hit
highest level since the 1960s I'm just
trying to get my head around the fact
that you know you say you believe in low
taxes you're a chancellor who run for
the leadership saying he was going to
cut corporation tax and now this is a
situation you are presiding over with
the economy I mean it takes a certain
amount of mental gymnastics to get there
well look at where that graph starts to
go up we had a global pandemic we've had
an energy crisis I'm actually very proud
of the fact that we're a society which
does believe in having a safety net and
despite the fact that our GDP fell by uh
20 at one point during the pandemic we
still kept unemployment low we haven't
seen thousands of people thrown onto the
Dole because we stepped in but that
costs money and I think it was right
that we responded in the way we did when
we did
um and because we have to be responsible
with our public finances yes we are
having to put taxes up temporarily but
the path we're going on look at our
track record bringing down taxes on the
low lowest paid in the Autumn statement
record is a tax department
well I've just told you the first time
you don't pay a penny of tax or National
Insurance on the first thousand pounds
you earn every month uh last was Autumn
despite all the challenges we Face we
reduce business rates by an average of
10 percent so a conservative government
will always cut taxes when we can but we
won't run out of money we'll be
responsible with public finances because
businesses also so if you need stability
and if they're going to invest they need
to know that they've got a government
that is being sensible sound money
responsible it sounds you know very
Steady As She Goes
you know you're the chancellor right
this is probably the job you dreamed of
when you were a kid what's the vision
what's the big idea well I um when I was
young I took the decision not to get a
well-paid job in the city but to set up
my own business and that was the best
decision I ever took and I became
Chancellor because I want to help people
like me who had Big Dreams for the
future and I have Big Dreams for the
future of our country as well so that
means taking difficult decisions when
you have huge challenges like a pandemic
like an energy crisis it means being
responsible with public finances but
look at what's happened to this country
in the last 13 years we have built the
third biggest Tech economy in the world
after American China the biggest life
science sector in Europe where we
discovered one of the two big covert
vaccines one of the major covid
treatments the largest film and TV
industry in Europe we have got so many
exciting things happening in our country
country and I want to make sure that we
go from strength to strength you talk
about your vision there as a child you
know you were a radical on tax when you
ran for the leadership when you were
chair of the house select committee you
wanted to transform the NHS and now it
feels a bit like you know you're running
the economy as if you're Jeremy from
accounts well I think you have to wait
uh and see what I say on Wednesday
um but you know Jeremy the chancellor
will be responsible with public finances
I make absolutely no apology for that I
think families who want to know that
their money is safe need to know that
they have a responsible Chancellor and a
responsible conservative government but
what you will also see on Wednesday is
that we have a plan to tackle the
biggest problems we face as a country
whether it's a lack of investment
whether it's businesses not able to
recruit and we have a very exciting plan
for the future of our country that will
make us one of the most prosperous in
the world
um away from the budgets um How
concerned are you by the collapse of
Silicon Valley Bank UK well I think the
first thing to say is the governor of
the bank of England has made it very
clear there is no systemic risk to our
financial system so people should be
reassured on that basis but there is a
serious risk to our technology and Life
Sciences sectors many of whom bank with
this bank that most people won't have
heard of the Silicon Valley Bank but it
happens to look after the money of some
of our most promising and exciting
businesses and so I want to reassure
people I've been in discussions over the
weekend until late last night with a
Chancellor with the Prime Minister the
governor of the bank of England many
other people and we are working at PACE
on a solution we will bring forward very
soon plans to make sure people are able
to meet their cash flow requirements pay
their staff but obviously what we want
to do is to find a longer term solution
that minimizes or even avoids completely
losses to some of our promising
companies could you step in with
taxpay's money to try and Safeguard jobs
I don't want to go into what the
solution is but what I will say because
people are worried about paying their
staff next week is we will come forward
with a solution that helps those very
very important companies with things
like payroll and their their cash flow
requirements but we also want to put in
place a longer term solution so that
their Futures are secure and how quickly
should we expect to see this package
well as I say we've been working at PACE
this only uh started to happen on Friday
we've been working at PACE uh over the
weekend through the night and the Prime
Minister and I and the governor of the
bank of England are absolutely
determined to do everything we can to
protect the future of these very very
important companies thank you very much
thank you
well that was the chancellor talking
ahead of his budget speech this coming
Wednesday so let's speak shall we to the
woman who is going to be responding for
the labor party we can talk to the child
Chancellor Rachel Reeves who joins us
now live thank you for being with us
um just firstly we were just talking to
the chancellor about the collapse of
Silicon Valley Bank UK How concerned are
you and should we be ready to put
taxpayers money in to try and help job
losses
look of course I am concerned about the
collapse of Silicon Valley Bank because
for startups and Venture Capital if uh
life sciences and Tech businesses
Silicon Valley Bank is an important
source of finance and I am slightly
concerned about the urgency that you
heard from the chancellor there because
when markets open tomorrow morning a lot
of businesses in the UK are not going to
be clear about how they can pay the
wages of their staff and whether their
deposits of Silicon Valley Bank and
their financing Arrangements uh um are
still in place so I would urge the
government to do more than offer warm
words but come forward with a specific
plans I don't know the full exposure I'm
not sure if the government do but they
must by tomorrow morning come up with a
plan to give reassurance to those
crucial parts of our account me you know
there's conversations going on as we
speak so I'm sure we'll be hearing more
about the plan to try and solve any
difficulties with Silicon Valley bank as
soon as possible
um I just want to talk a bit about Gary
lineker if I may before we get on to
your economic plan Jeremy Hunt very
careful saying that look BBC
impartiality needs to be respected it'd
be wrong for him to comment but some
would say what's at stake isn't up
impartiality but Independence do you
think that the BBC looks too close to
the party of government
I found it pretty unedifying spectacle
over the last few days as Tory MPS and
Tory ministers put pressure on the BBC
about Gary lineker and if you compare it
to what happened with Richard Sharp the
chairman of the BBC a few weeks ago when
it was discovered that he had helped
facilitate an 800 000 pound loan for the
Prime Minister Tory MPS and Tory
ministers said nothing to see here
that's totally fine and yet when a
football commentator dares to disagree
with the government and express concerns
over one of their policies they all take
to the airwaves to criticize they say
they believe in free speech when they
agree with what someone says but it's
all about impartiality when they don't
so I think we do need a sense of
proportionality here and I don't think
that Gary line occur should have been
taken off air at the same time that's
not just conservative MPS who weren't
happy with the tweet and in particular
the comparison with 1930s Germany the
Holocaust Education trust spoke out
against that when I spoke to laborers
Emily Thornbury she said that she
thought Gary Lindner could have gone too
far as well
it's not about whether you agree or
disagree with what he said I wouldn't
have used the language that Gary lineker
used but do I think he should be taken
off TV from doing commentary on the
football no I don't and I think that
that was out of proportion
that there is a crisis of confidence now
in the leadership of the BBC you
mentioned there Richard Sharp who failed
to declare his role in helping to
facilitate a loan to Boris Johnson the
BBC's director General Tim Davey has
apologized to viewers do they need to
consider their positions
the people who I think are at fault here
are the conservative
is and ministers who lined up to
criticize Gary lineker putting pressure
on the BBC to take him um off uh air I
can't believe it
just to jump in because I accept that
there have been conservative MPS and
members of the government who've
criticized the Tweet by Gary lineker but
you've said yourself that you know
you're able to disagree with what he
said there hasn't really been many
members of the government calling for
him to be sacked or come Affair unless
I'm mistaken
well my understanding is well I mean you
just see all the tweets and the letters
being organized by conservative MPS
Sophie they're putting on top
intolerable pressure on the BBC to take
action over uh Gary lineker in fact
they've got more to say about Gary
lineker than they do about the cost of
living crisis about the state of our NHS
about the uh failed Asylum system and
the failure to protect our borders more
to say about Gary lineker than frankly
anything else including all of the
issues affecting all of our constituents
on a day-to-day basis that is the
priority now of the conservatives some
culture War but rather than the
interests and the concerns of people in
their day-to-day lives that is just all
wrong well let's talk about some of
those concerns now shall we because it
is budget week you of course have got a
very important role at Shadow Chancellor
as well now you spent a long time trying
to prove that labor can be trusted on
the economy you said you would have iron
clad this plan you promised I will never
make a spending commitment without
telling you where the money is coming
from you know some labor voters might
think that if they look at the state of
Public Services then actually that's
what you should be looking at doing
rather than trying to outtour the
conservative party on spending
well you saw what happened last year
when the conservatives mini budget
crashed financial markets putting
pensions in Peril and resulting in that
long-term Tory mortgage penalty where
anybody remortgaging this year is
looking at paying thousands of pounds
more a year so I am absolutely
determined that as Chancellor I would
have an iron grip on the public finances
and any announcement that I make about
spending and about priorities will say
where the money is going to come from
that's why for example I've said that
labor would extend the windfall tax on
the huge profits that energy Giants are
making and use that money to keep
people's energy bills low it's why I've
said that they would get the rid of the
non-dom tax status because if you make
Britain your home you should pay your
taxes here and we would use that money
for one of the biggest ever expansions
of the NHS Workforce and free breakfast
clubs at all primary schools so when I
say that we I'm making something a
priority I will tell you always where
the money is going to come from but it
does also mean that there are some
things that a labor government might not
be able to do as quickly as it wants
because of those constraints but I would
never put the public finances in Peril
in the way that the Tories did just a
few months ago because it is ordinary
people and businesses that pay for the
price for that sort of mess
so if you have an iron grip on the
public finances if keeping borrowing
down is key why is the labor party
proposing to spend 28 billion pounds a
year on the green Prosperity plan
well I Look to what President Biden is
doing in the U.S and the response of the
EU and of Australia and countries around
the world that are determined to get for
their countries a share of the
investment in the industries of the
future and President Biden is turning
the Rust Belt into an electric vehicle
belt he is getting good manufacturing
jobs back to the US and is encouraging
businesses to invest there and Britain
is frankly in the changing rooms whilst
other countries are in this Global race
and a chancellor has got to know when to
say no but they also know need to know
when to make prudent investments in
things to get growth and productivity
and investment going and that has been a
failure of this government when we are
at the bottom of the league tables on
productivity investment and growth and
it will be ordinary people paying the
price for that if you look for example
Sophia what the office of budget
responsibility say they say that
delaying action on getting to Net Zero
by a decade it doubles the cost of
getting there so it is a responsible
thing to invest and to prioritize these
jobs and these industries and that is
what I would do as Chancellor because
there are huge opportunities here to get
us out of this low growth low
productivity cycle that we are in and
turbocharge our economy
you know I'm not arguing against the
importance of investing in climate
change but I just want to put it in
context you know the government spends
just over four billion pounds a year on
child care and you're planning to spend
seven times as much on a green
Prosperity plan which is funded by
borrowing I mean these are important
priorities but how can you say that you
have an ironclad grip on the public
finances oh just as long as you don't
look at these massive spending
commitments that we've made over here
well our commitments for the green
Prosperity plan are all in the context
of Labor's fiscal rules which involve
getting a grip on day-to-day spending
and bringing debt down as a share of GDP
and subject to that we will invest in
the things that get our economy growing
so this is part of Labor's fiscal rules
but it is about prioritizing investment
in these industries of the future as
every other country around the world is
doing and the moment to act is now there
is an urgency here because if we want
those jobs and those investment and
every other country in the world wants
them to we have got to have a serious
plan to invest alongside business
through the national wealth fund that a
labor government would create to ensure
that those jobs and investment come here
to Britain otherwise we'll find in the
future that we're importing all of our
cars because we failed to build the
electric vehicles here that we are
importing gas and electricity because we
failed to invest in green hydrogen that
we're importing steel because we fail to
invest in green still I won't allow that
future for the UK where we fall behind
our competitors we've got to act to get
those jobs and investment here in the UK
that's what businesses are telling me
that is what the obr are saying in terms
of the costs of this investment and
other countries are acting I want to see
the chancellor at in the budget this
week
another key focus on the budget will be
growth economic growth and do you accept
that one easy way of improving that
would be to increase targeted
immigration
well I don't think that the immigration
lever is the answer to every uh problem
our mission of an incoming labor
government is to have the highest
sustained growth with good jobs and
productivity in all parts of the country
and that means seizing the opportunities
in towns and cities across the UK
through our national wealth funds and
our green Prosperity plan through our
reforms to make Britain the best place
to start and grow a business but we've
got to be training people up here in
Britain for those jobs in the industries
of the future it's why we have committed
to reform the apprenticeship Levy which
at the moment has seen the number of
apprentices fall and businesses spur
that spurn the system and why we have
said that we would devolve skills and
employment support to local communities
to ensure that businesses where they are
have the skills they need to succeed so
that would be my priority to making sure
that businesses have the skills they
need and that young people and people
retraining later in life have the
opportunity to take up the jobs that are
available in the UK economy
and just finally it has brexit made us
poorer
well look the deal that the government
got is clearly not working for
businesses and every Economist uh says
and all of the forecasts say that that
deal has made our country uh poorer is
why we have said that one of our
priorities for getting that growth would
be reforming the brexit deal not going
back into the single Market or Customs
Union not bringing back free movement
but practical changes that can help
British businesses export and bring
investment to the UK so a Veterinary
agreement to help our great farming and
fishing industries support for us great
Services sector with a mutual
recognition of professional
qualifications helping our brilliant
creative Industries with better deals
about touring rights for artists UK
participation in Horizon to help our
universities uh succeed and bring in
investment so there are practical
changes that we can make so that we can
ensure our economy grow and that we can
take advantage of the export
opportunities that exist but that the
government's trade and cooperation
agreement is cutting British businesses
out of okay thank you very much indeed
Sarah Chancellor there Rachel Reeves
thank you
you're watching at safer Ridge on Sunday
well we've heard the two competing
economic Visions from the chancellor and
the shadow Chancellor and it's still to
come on the program this morning we are
going to be talking to the former
Chancellor Philip Hammond on what makes
a good budget and how to deal with China
and a little later on we're also going
to be hearing from the former Liverpool
and England Star John Barnes on how he
thinks the BBC can get himself out of
the Gary lineker crisis
[Music]
thank you
well as the chancellor puts the
finishing touches to his budget one man
knows more than most the pressure of
trying to balance the books while
pleasing the party faithful Philip now
Lord Hammond was the chancellor of the
exchequer under Theresa May between 2016
and 2019 and he joins us now good
morning thanks very much for being with
us
um just before we get to the budget I'm
quite interested to hear your views on
the collapse of Silicon Valley Bank How
concerned should we be well look it's
not going to affect many individuals in
the UK because not many people bank with
Silicon Valley Bank but it is going to
affect the very important fintech sector
in our economy where there's a huge
concentration around Silicon Valley Bank
UK and there's a lot of small early
stage businesses that are quite
important to this economy quite
important to keeping our financial
services sector at The Cutting Edge who
will be very very nervous today so I
hope that in the course of the day the
government the bank of England
Rothschilds who are managing this
process can come up with a solution that
allows those businesses to get access to
their funds tomorrow morning and
reassure their customers their investors
because this is a very important Dynamic
sector and we don't want to see it
suffer a massive own goal here I mean
those plans have been worked up as we
speak what kind of things do you think
they should be looking at I mean should
taxpayers money be on the table well I
think whatever happens the bank of
England is going to have to provide some
significant additional liquidity to
whoever buys svb and I think that's the
most likely outcome that it will be
specificity means money cash money yeah
because as I understand it svb has good
quality assets it's not a question of
the firm's bust it's a question of it's
unable to turn those assets Into Cash
quickly and the bank of England can help
there the bank of England can step in
and Loan it money as it routinely does
to Banks to allow them to pay their
depositors settle the nerves of the
market and then unwind its assets in a
more orderly fashion over a period of
weeks or even months thank you very much
that's interesting uh now we heard from
the chancellor earlier on the program
um there's a lot of jitteriness among
conservatives about the level of tax in
the UK cooperation tax obviously due to
rise by six percent and the chancellor
was pretty clear that he's going to
stick with that do you think that's the
right decision I think it's the right
decision for now
um I of course as I've said before lower
corporation tax is always better than
higher corporation tax for economic
growth
um but the thing that really matters to
businesses is the effective rate of
Taxation and I expect we're going to
hear the chancellor making some moves on
allowances and reliefs so that for many
businesses particularly those that are
investing heavily
um the effective rate of corporation tax
is lowered a bit but I think what
business will be looking for is first of
all a signal from Jeremy Hunt that in
the medium to long term he does want to
see corporation tax lower that he
doesn't see 25 percent of some new
normal that's a a tax for a moment in
time and secondly they're going to want
to see that apart from tax the
government recognizes and is tackling
the challenges of economic growth there
are many problems facing this economy at
the moment and if business sees the
government moving to deal with those
problems it'll be a little bit less
concerned about the higher rate of tax
how do you think they should be moving
to do it well I think there are three
big challenges for any conservative
Chancellor the first is he's got to
demonstrate fiscal responsibility and
especially given the circumstances in
which Rishi sunak came into office I
think they've done a great job in
stabilizing the markets stabilizing the
perception of the UK's public finances
but the job is absolutely not done and
we're still borrowing eye-wateringly
large amounts of money I've read in the
papers Jeremy Hunt might have 20 or 30
billion pounds of Headroom what that
Headroom really means is that he might
have he might be borrowing 20 30 billion
pounds less than we thought we would be
borrowing it's not real money we're
massively in the red so that job is not
finished and he's got to show an iron
resolution to complete that job secondly
he's got to continue the battle against
inflation because it's inflation that's
eroding people's living standards but
thirdly and I think this is where we're
going hopefully to see some strong
signaling
um in the budget
um he's got to set out a growth agenda
so that when we get through this period
of fiscal difficulty when we get out of
the period of high inflation we've at
least got something to look forward to
that the economy will return to growth
because the forecasts at the moment are
not very positive yes the UK economy
hasn't gone into a deep recession but it
is still way behind its peer group of
international economies do you think a
recession is likely
um if if there is it looks like it'll be
a shallow recession so we'll either
hover just above or just below the line
on recession but the real problem here
is looking out a year or two years what
we're not seeing is any signals that
will return to strong economic growth
and we need something a bit more than an
anemic sort of three-quarters of a
percent one percent one and a quarter
percent we need to find a way of getting
this economy back to growing at two
percent a year year in year out that's
the way we raise people's living
standards would Jeremy Hunt talked a lot
about getting people back into the
workplace which is pretty hard right if
you're left the workplace and you can
afford to do so it's quite difficult to
get those people back in I mean there is
an easy way to do this right to fill the
vacancies which would be to relax
certain immigration rules should they be
looking at that so the problems in our
economy are mainly on the supply side of
the economy it's not that there isn't
demand it's that there isn't there
aren't the resources to meet that demand
um there isn't the land with planning
permission to build the houses that
people want or the factories that people
want there aren't workers to fill the
jobs that are available so you're
absolutely right the the most obvious
way to deal particularly with the need
for lower skilled workers would be to
relax immigration rules but of course
um there is another political agenda out
there which is very concerned about
levels of immigration and this all gets
mixed up with the brexit debate and the
end of free movement to be honest do you
basically think that the most sensible
thing to do from a purely economic
perspectives is to relax immigration
rules but it's the politics that's
present preventing you from doing that
if I was a Chancellor and I was
unconstrained I would relax the
immigration rules in a very specific and
narrow way in that I would allow I would
issue a certain number of short-term
work visas for people who would come
here to do mainly lower skilled work
with no right to remain no rights of
settlement come stay three years work
and leave Jeremy Hunt won't do that
because of political constraints what
he's going to do I think and the
signaling is pretty clear is focus on
trying to get people who are already
here into the workforce so people who've
retired early getting them back in
people who are thinking of retiring
early deterring them from doing that
people who are out because of long-term
health or mental health problems helping
them to get back into the workforce and
I think you'll see a mixture of carrots
and sticks some generous child care
support some additional work training
and support for people who want to get
back into the workforce coupled with a
slightly tighter regime for benefits for
people who choose to stay out of the
workforce for long periods um I just
want to zoom out for a minute
um the conservative parties polling is
abysmal right um it's looking it's not
great yeah that's one way of putting it
um what do you think the conservative
party needs to do if you're going to
have any chance of winning the next
election it feels to me like you're
focusing an awful lot on red wall seats
and perhaps not on the blue wall seats
like the ones that you used to represent
yeah well I think um to be honest Rishi
sunax doing it what needs to be done the
only thing he can do after a period of
extreme turbulence is uh demonstrate
again to people that conservative
governments deliver fiscal stability get
inflation down and promote sound money
and can deliver a growth agenda for the
medium term that's the bit that's
missing at the moment and the thing that
I really want to see on Wednesday is a
narrative that shows that you know
problems with backbench Tory groups who
um don't like house building for example
or who don't want closer relations with
major trading partners like Europe or
who don't want to see relaxation of
migration rules can be overcome the Tory
party must go into the next election as
the party of fiscal responsibility and
economic growth it can't win an election
unless it is the champion of those two
principles you're talking about the need
for close links for trading partners
another of those trading partners is
China I was quite interested in the
speech you made in February where you
talked about the trading relationship
and you said this you said for all the
noises we hear many of our Global
Partners have been partly increasing
their share of trade with China well we
have seen our stagnate over the pandemic
period time now to roll the sleeves up
get that market share climbing so you
think we should be doing more trade with
China yes I do I think
um and we have to be clear-eyed about
China this has always been my view on
China China has a very different
political system very different culture
very different history from us and we
disagree profoundly with them on some
important issues but we disagree
profoundly with a lot of people on
important issues and we still trade with
them China is our fourth biggest trading
partner our sixth biggest export Market
we Proclaim that the UK is a great
global trading Nation we cannot simply
turn our back on the world's second
largest economy and our fourth largest
trading partner we have to engage with
them and we have to be clear that simply
because we're trading with someone
doesn't mean we endorse their politics
or their uh their political culture uh
in any way but we've got a long
tradition in the UK of trade-led
diplomacy and I think if we build our
trading links we then work on the other
issues that divide us I mean a lot of
your colleagues would disagree with that
and not least because of Human Rights
abuses that we've seen in Hong Kong the
treatment of the uyghurs reports the
Sunday Times today that the UK wants to
see Tick Tock banned from all UK
government electronic devices that's a
specific security issue and we need to
look at that so that's on its on its
merits but we trade with lots of people
um where we with whom we have human
rights concerns we have to be pragmatic
about the fact that we're talking about
the world's second largest economy here
and somehow I think some of my
colleagues have got a mindset that when
we trade with somebody we're doing them
a favor
believe me it doesn't work like that we
need to trade we are a trading Nation
after brexit after covid after the
energy price crisis we have a challenge
in this country about how to deliver
growth how to earn our living so that we
can maintain our Public Services we can
improve people's standards of living in
the future and trade has to be a part of
that it's not a choice for us we've got
to get on and trade with the world now
before I let you go I want to get your
take on the garyland Corral I quite like
questions where I don't actually know
what the answer is going to be and with
you and Gary lineke and the BBC I feel
like I genuinely don't know what your
view is on this which is always quite a
good position to start off with
what is your view is the entire tour to
express his beliefs or does it go
against the impartiality of the BBC so I
think there's two things and I'm not an
expert in this area yeah there's two
things
um struck me reading this debate there's
we're in danger of confusing two
separate issues
um there's the impartiality of the BBC
which is a very important principle of
course for a public service broadcaster
and and it's I think probably by and
large the BBC usually gets it mostly
right because and I know that because
people in my party feel that the BBC is
institutionally biased against it and I
know that people in the labor party
equally feel that the BBC is
institutionally biased against it so
it's probably doing something about
right then there's a separate issue
about whether individuals who are
closely associated with large
corporations can publicly Express views
which are highly controversial and are
not the views of that Corporation and I
think generally speaking that is not
acceptable it's even more important when
the corporation is a public body like
the BBC or indeed the Civil Service the
same would be true of a senior civil
servant tweeting out
um something that was highly
controversial but look it goes further
than that if a senior executive of Sky
were to tweet something highly
controversial they'd have a problem with
their management if a senior executive
of one of Britain's major but it's also
slightly it's different as well because
the license fee money as well right yeah
of course there's the public element but
if you talk to senior Executives or
senior figures across
high-profile businesses in the UK I
think you'll find them all saying that
they are extremely cautious about
publicly expressing views unless that
are controversial unless they are
clearly the views of the corporation
they work for very finely is there a
risk that BBC looks too close to the
government right now that they've
stepped in double footed if you're like
a double footed tackle on Gary lineker
we have The Rao over Richard Sharp not
disclosing his emboldment in
facilitating a loan to Boris Johnson is
it swinging too much well this is the
point isn't it it no doubt there will be
many people on the left of politics
saying look at this this is another
example of the BBC cozying up to the
Tory party I can tell you that the vast
majority of my former colleagues in the
Parliamentary Tory party see the BBC in
a different lighters
it feels like the scrutiny is on their
closeness to the conservative party and
it's right that there should be um
scrutiny on it okay thank you very much
indeed thank you
all just been talking about Gary lineker
who of course has got himself into a bit
of trouble with the BBC before the match
the day presenter has been warned in the
past that tweeting about politics was
against the corporation's impartiality
rules but the latest Rao has not only
seen the former footballer taken off air
it's also seen many of his colleagues
come together in support with programs
canceled and many have said Ms at the
BBC's own mating so what is going to
happen next well we can talk now to the
former Liverpool and England's Striker
John Barnes great to have you on the
program and you've said that you're 100
behind Gary lineker why is that
well first of all there are two issues
let's listen to the gentleman before in
terms of impartiality I don't know when
the BBC have ever been impartial in fact
BBC's reporting on the Guitar World Cup
was anything but impartial so it seems
that they want to pick and choose when
they want to be impartial criticizing
others or criticizing other countries or
other political parties or other
religions seems to be okay but of course
if you then criticize what goes on in
this country then it seems that they
will then come up with this impartiality
rule the second thing which a lot of
people took um offense to is is the
perception that Gary was was equating
um Britain to to Nazi Germany which he
wasn't what he said was the language
used regarding the refugees is similar
to the language used in 1930s Germany
which it was and of course we can see
how that ended up and Gary is not saying
I'm not saying that that's how it's
going to end up but of course the
language used in terms of creating this
perception of an unworthy Refugee very
much like the Jews were unworthy um to
be German and Germans were better than
Jews that was the language that was used
and that's what we're saying here we're
talking about the the refugees coming
over and the language used towards the
refugees coming over on boats in terms
of them being rapists in terms of them
being criminals is different to the
refugees from the Ukraine and that is
what we have to to address and that is
what I want Gary and everybody
supporting him to talk about us
talking about the worthiness of
different groups of people because
that's how discrimination starts be it
men women towards the men in terms of
the worthiness of a woman towards a man
blacks towards whites gays towards
straight people and a Syrian refugee
coming over on a boat as in relation to
a Ukrainian Refugee coming over we don't
hear a language from the Ukrainian
refugees situation talking about rapists
and murderers but we heard about the
Iraqis and the syrians and that's what I
would like Garian people to talk about
the worthiness of everybody including
the Syrian refugees in relation to the
Ukrainian refugees
really important point
s strong views about right but I guess
what some would argue is that is Gary
lineker the right person to be entering
this debate he's paid license fee money
that he is presenter of the BBC's
Flagship program is it right that this
kind of political uh debate should be
entering the World of Sport
should Gary lineker would Gary Lincoln
be the right person to talk about the
lgbtq rights and human rights in Qatar
we can't have it both ways we accept
that so why can't he talk about it here
so this is the point I'm making about
impartiality and we're saying that stick
to sports but when we want to criticize
other countries or other religions we
then say yes let the sports people come
out and talk about that but don't
criticize what goes on in this country
we can't have it both ways
uh interesting are you talking there
about the sort of double standards and
what you would see as you can't have it
both ways certainly
um we've seen a wave of sports
presenters commentators refusing uh to
appear on the BBC in support of Gary
linear code do you think that they're
right to do that
well of course if that's what they
believe and they believe in what Gary's
talking about I'm not supporting Gary
because I'm Gary's friend or I played
with him I'm supporting him because I
believe it's right to do but as I said
let's not make this and this should not
be about Governor and the BBC pundit
supporting him this should be about the
refugees and them coming over and that's
the conversation that should be had now
this is a distraction to and I'm suppose
the government is quite happy with this
and distraction to the cost of living
crisis a distraction to you know the
working conditions for the nurses and
and and and and Railway workers and
postal workers so this is probably quite
welcome because of course no one's now
talking about real issues you know
because this really is just a sideshow
and it's inconsequential and it's
meaningless but we've had three or four
days and it will continue to run and I
think it's quite a welcome distraction
to really to real issues from the
government
how do you see it being resolved because
you have got the people who are
supporting Gary lineker refusing to if
you like costly invisible picket line
you've got the director General and the
BBC apologizing where does this go
what of course a compromise will be had
um they'll come back together the
profile of lots of people will be raised
the profile of the BBC will be raised
that they'll do the right thing and
it'll be the state of score will resume
very shortly with everybody being happy
do you think that the BBC guidelines
themselves need to be looked at and
perhaps it's a bit of unclarity shall we
say a lack of clarity in the guidelines
themselves
absolutely very ambiguous and of course
Gary is also freelance so as to whether
he is fully employed by the BBC so he's
able to say things and I suppose Gary
probably thought well if I'm in Qatar
talking about human rights abuses then
why can't I talk about what I believe to
be right here as well so I think there's
a lot of ambiguity to it and of course
I'm not a lawyer but you can pick
different things out of out of contracts
and say yes you're allowed to but you're
not allowed to and everybody has an
argument so you know
um
how can you become more clear uh without
saying you're completely impartial you
can't mention it at all evening in
private life even if you're a freelance
uh but as I said I'm just sad that this
has been going on for so long when we
have many more issues uh to talk about
if you had a call to present match the
day
no no no no no I'm uh I think they've
lost my number I'm I'm called by many
people for many years you know what if
you volunteer to do it now I better be
on the phone straight away would you do
it
well only because only because there's
nobody else no I wouldn't do it
presenting if I was able to present I
would think about it but I got my
presenting Days Are Over
um but I suppose that anybody who's
going to be doing it now is because
there's nobody else to do it who can do
it but I won't be one of them no
thank you very much uh good to talk to
you today John Barnes there
well as John Barnes was saying there is
lots of other issues for us to get stuck
into other than the tweets of Gary
lineker and one of them is the SMP
leadership competition the three
candidates took to the stage in their
first uh we'll be taking the stage in
the first televised debate this week oh
and it became clear how deep those
divisions in the party have become and
Nicholas sturgeon's shocked decision to
stand down as leader really has left the
party fighting to Define its future and
perhaps the future of Scotland well
tomorrow night all three candidates will
go live on Sky News with that political
editor Beth Rigby host being the debate
so definitely one uh to tune into well
joining us now from Aberdeen is the MSP
for Edinburgh Eastern s p leadership
candidate Ash Regan thank you so much
for being on the uh program
what's your position on Gary lineker
then
sorry can you repeat that Sophie what's
your position on Gary lineker
yes I was asked this the other night
actually and I hadn't seen his tweets
um but yeah I think the way he's been
treated
um is pretty terrible actually he should
be allowed to express his views and I
think morally what's going on at the
moment with the conservatives and their
position on this
um is morally reprehensible
uh strong words there uh on the row over
that Gary lindika tweet well look I'm
very keen to talk about your own pitch
right you want to be the next leader of
the s p you want to be the next first
Minister what is the big idea
well as you can understand
um the membership of the SNP are very
concerned about the the way that the UK
gov the UK is going if you think about
what we're facing at the moment we've
got skyrocketing energy costs because of
the conservative mismanagement of the
economy inflation is making everything
much more expensive for families you
know including food and we were dragged
out of the EU against our will which is
having a disproportionate impact on the
Scottish economy so things are looking
difficult at the moment up here and I
think it's entirely right to be able to
look at this question again of
Independence and that is something that
obviously the members of the s p are
very interested in when and how would we
be able to get to an independent
Scotland
well that's the question isn't it you
know you launched your campaign with a
slogan Independence nothing less but the
government of Westminster have refused
to Grant the referendum so how do you
get there
they have and that is obviously within
their gift to refuse a referendum and if
you think about it the reason that
they're refusing a referendum is because
they don't want to allow Scotland to
express its Democratic will at the ball
The Ballot Box but what we need to
remember here is that not many countries
achieve their independence through
referendums actually that's fairly
unusual and actually it's much more
normal to use a scheduled election to
use The Ballot Box in order for the
people to express their will
you know the problem is though if you
know you say you you'd use a election as
a de facto referendum but but who are
you to say that people are only voting
on Independence you know they might
think the S P's got the best policy on
the cost of living they might think that
you ashrigan have got the best policy
when it comes to the gender recognition
act and that's not how the Westminster
government would say either is it
so the the facto referendum is a
different it's a similar um strategy but
it's a different strategy the de facto
referendum is is for on a single
occasion on a single issue and you're
quite right to point out that at the
moment with the things that are going on
right now energy crisis cost of living
crisis problems in the NHS across the UK
you know the public will quite rightly
um not want to fight a single issue
um de facto referendum so that's not
what I'm suggesting what I'm suggesting
is the voter empowerment mechanism and
this sets up a permanent mechanism to
run each and every election in Scotland
as an opportunity for the people of
Scotland to express their will over
whether they want to govern themselves
so the trigger point for that would be
50 plus one and that is a strategy that
used to be widely accepted this was an
SNP policy up until about
um the year 2000 it was previously
accepted by the conservatives in
Westminster Margaret Thatcher herself
had said all this policy years ago that
this was perfectly Democratic and it was
a legitimate way and for the Scottish
people to express their will so I'm
under I expect that the UK government
would understand that Democratic mandate
if that was expressed by the people of
Scotland and that they would recognize
it they often start off saying no but
then they always come to the table and
eventually say yes okay uh we'll have to
see on that one now I hope this doesn't
sound too harsh but you have got an
absolute mountain to climb uh in this
leadership competition a recent ipsos
Scotland poll found 32 saying Kate
Forbes would make the best first
Minister Hunter Yousef was on 24 you're
on eight percent
if you don't win who are you going to
endorse
I'm in this competition to win it I've
been having a lot of support expressed
to me by the membership we have to
remember it's it's fairly difficult I
think to get an accurate idea of what
the s p membership are thinking at the
moment we understand that there's a
large amount of membership that are
still undecided um it's a very short
contest so it's certainly true to say
um that I um probably the least well
known out of the candidates and with the
less name recognition
um and it is an opportunity for me to
work that bit harder to set out my stall
if you like on what I'm proposing to do
um but I have had many people get in
touch with me recently to say that they
think that I am the only hope for the
asmp we are at Crossroads at the moment
in terms of where we go next and I
believe I'm the candidate that is
setting out a credible Democratic means
for Scotland to express its will at
about box and give Scotland that choice
over their own future
I thought it was interesting to hear
that you said you say that you think
it's a conflict of interest that Peter
Morrow and Nicole sturgeon's husband to
remain as the s p chief executive while
this leadership contest is going along I
mean he doesn't have a role in the
ballot why do you think that
well effectively he's running the
contest to
um replace
um his wife and I think if we think of
that in a different way you know that
would be like Carrie counting the votes
for boris's successor and I think many
people would think that that would be
fairly unusual I think there is a
conflict of interest here my campaign
team we've set out that we think it
should be an independent third party
company that should be running the
contest and that we've also asked for
there to be a neutral Observer as well
just to make sure everything is above
board we need to be careful in this too
and we're the largest party in Scotland
and the person that wins this contest
will not just be leader of the SNP but
they'll actually also become the first
minister of the country this is very
significant it's very important and it's
important for both the members of the
SNP but also the wider country that
there's trust in this process that it's
all above board and it's transparent
now you disagreed with Nicola sturgeon
over the gender recognition Reform Bill
you resigned from government so you
could vote against it Nicholas station
said you didn't approach her with your
concerns is that true
um I did have many conversations inside
government with special advisors I
raised this issue in 2019 at cabinet
with Nicholas sturgeon so My Views
inside government were well known on on
this issue
so she's not really being honest in your
opinion then
well as I said I also signed an open
letter with many of my colleagues in
2019 to the newspapers so I don't think
it's credible to say that my views were
not well known okay now just finally you
said earlier in the interview that you
were the least well known candidate in
the competition so I thought we'd do
something about that with a couple of
quickfire questions to end
um ready
here's your political hero
um I don't really have one I admire many
people who've made big social changes
but um there's certainly not anyone in
in the recent history that I I would
name particularly
ever broken the law
um not that I can remember no
definitely
sorry guilty pleasure
guilty pleasure um watching a very
lightweight television when I'm tired
got one more example Give an example I'm
terrible on this stuff as well so no
judgment here
um Bridgerton or something like that a
guilty pleasure
and what's your greatest achievement
well I was I was very proud actually of
being able to stand up in the Scottish
Parliament
you know um with a very small number of
people actually and make the case for
the fact that there was a conflict of
rights under the gender recognition
Reform Bill
um there was a great sense I think in
Scotland that many the voices of women
particularly hadn't been heard during
this process and so I was proud to give
voice to that during the stage three
debate and raise those issues that women
had um expressed me and make make that
case in public for them and speak for
them
okay thank you very much for being on
the program uh good to have you on one
of the first series of debates we're
doing of interview shall I say that
we're doing with the leadership
candidates thank you
thank you
and a reminder that tomorrow night sky
news is going to have a special debate
on the race to become Scotland's first
Minister it is definitely going to be
worth your time Atletico editor Beth
Rigby is going to be joined by the three
candidates that's Kate Forbes under ufes
and Asha Regan who of course we've just
heard from there so that is tomorrow
evening 7pm live from Edinburgh so put
that in your calendars
that is it for this week's safety Ridge
on Sunday busy show today in a moment
after the break we are going to be
running through today's interviews
seeing what we've learned we're going to
be joined here in the studio by our
political correspondent Liz Bates thanks
for joining us this Sunday morning
[Music]
so welcome back now it's time for the
take where we pick apart some of the
interviews over the last hour and also
just talk a bit more widely about some
of the people who call it stories of the
week now we're joined I'm very pleased
to say by our political correspondent
Liz Bates who's here in the studio with
us this Sunday morning Liz it was such a
strange show today because it's one of
these ones that you have in in your
diary for ages right the pre-budget show
it takes a certain uh amounts of it
always goes the same way right you have
the chancellor talking about what's
going to be in the budget you have the
shadow Chancellor and then it felt that
the whole thing was thrown a complete
purple by this Gary lineker story that
has just exploded completely and I was
watching the show this morning thinking
uh you're actually in quite a bizarre
position when you have the chancellor on
a former Chancellor
um a a contender to be the next leader
of the Scottish government and you have
to ask them about a tweet that a
footballer did but that's the situation
that we're in at the moment and of
course it just seemed to in some ways
quite trivial but there are so many
underlying problems that have been kind
of brought into the open by what's gone
on with Gary lineker and it really is
potentially a bit of a problem for the
conservative partner I think that's why
you saw this morning Jeremy Hunt trying
to step back from from it a little bit I
think that's something that's come from
on high at number 10 the Prime Minister
wanting to step back from it the last
thing that they want this to turn into
is a narrative that the conservative
party has been sort of having influence
within the BBC putting pressure on in
various ways and getting to the point
where one of uh their biggest stars and
you could describe him I think fairly
absolutely as a National Treasure is
being silenced via the government
through at the top tier of the BBC and I
think there's a danger of that you can
see them trying to pull back from it
yeah that's it and also your point there
that you might think it's trivial but
actually it's not trivial because it
goes to the hearts of government
influence in the media the independence
of the BBC plus match today one of the
most watched programs and suddenly
there's no commentary on it what is
going on uh it's interesting to hear Liz
saying there about how she felt that
Jeremy Hunt was rowing back shall we say
about some of his criticism of Gary
Lincoln's comments and I felt that to
the interview let's have a quick lesson
well I personally profoundly disagree
with the comments that he made but I
think what this shows and indeed the
related debate about the BBC Chairman's
appointment and we should wait until the
investigation is completely independent
investigation before passing judgment on
that
is that impartiality at the BBC is
really important the reason that it is a
great National Institution that we all
treasure so much is because it is
respected for impartiality but I don't
think it's for me to decide how that
issue you previously said that he should
apologize as I say I I don't agree with
what he said I I as a government we want
to get on with solving the issue of
illegal migration partly because I'm
very proud we're one of the most open
and tolerant countries in the world when
it comes to Legal migration but if you
believe in BBC Independence then it's
not for the chancellor or any other
government minister to say how these
issues are resolved
I mean I asked him what three or four
times about whether he thought Gary
lindika should apologize which he has
previously done and he didn't take the
opportunity to do I mean I think that's
exactly what we're seeing we're seeing
them trying to uh extract themselves
from this route that they think could be
incredibly uh damaging and look there is
a long-standing problem with the BBC
trying to be totally separate from
government trying to be politically
impartial when at the same time it's
rather uniquely in this country has a
huge influence on British culture and
its financial future lies in the hands
of the government so there's always been
a bit of attention there I thought it
was really interesting this morning with
Jeremy Hunt the way he was quite willing
to praise the BBC as well and wanting to
be sort of quite balanced in that a real
shift when you think about the last few
years under Boris Johnson and
particularly Nadine Doris is the culture
secretary the hostility that has come
from this government towards the BBC and
I think that's partly why we've got to
this position they've been threatening
them for many years with removing the
license fee and being very critical in
public in a way that is I think quite
different from her previous
administrations and I think what you've
seen in Gary lineker is those festering
tensions coming to a head he's almost
become a lightning rod full of this and
now some of this stuff really has to
come out into the open yeah and that's
certainly I guess the labor view as well
isn't it right uh Rachel Reeves really
we were talking there about how Jeremy
help us run to lean back from the debate
well Rachel Williams is doing the
opposite she is leaning right into it
this is what happened when I spoke to
Shadow I found it pretty unedifying
spectacle over the last few days as Tory
MPS and Tory ministers put pressure on
the BBC about Gary lineker and if you
compare it to what happened with Richard
Sharp the chairman of the BBC a few
weeks ago when it was discovered that he
had helped facilitate an 800 000 pound
loan for the Prime Minister Tory MPS and
Tory Minister said nothing to see here
that's totally fine and yet when a
football commentator dares disagree with
the government and express concerns over
one of their policies they all take to
the airwaves to criticize they say they
believe in free speech when they agree
with what someone says but it's all
about impartiality when they don't so I
think we do need a sense of
proportionality here and I don't think
the Gary line occur should have been
taken off air
I think the backdrop to this is quite
important as well right
um because there is also a row over
Richard Charles the chairman of the BBC
and his involvement in facilitating an
800 000 pound loan to Boris Johnson
does this play into more widespread
concerns you think
I think it does play into a more
widespread concerns and exactly what I
was talking about earlier that difficult
relationship that the government has
with the BBC the issue with Richard
Sharp is ongoing but I think uh you know
that will clearly come up again
particularly in the context of
everything that's going on I do think on
Labor's position though you know really
Punchy there from Rachel Reeves they
have waited for a couple of days really
to see which way the wind is blowing and
now suddenly it's quite clear that Gary
lineker has many many uh very famous
very well-loved people on his side a few
days ago there were senior labor figures
um saying uh we're not really sure about
the Gary lineker comments maybe he
shouldn't maybe he's gone too far really
sitting on the fence and suddenly things
have changed and uh the momentum seems
to be very much behind Gary lineker and
now suddenly the labor party are very
much behind Gary lineker as well yeah
Emily Thornbury sat in the studio saying
she thought that he'd gone too far yeah
I don't think you'll hear that one right
now and that debate you have much today
families
um no but I'm aware that football exists
so I know you're I know you're a big
match of the Dayton Sophie uh yeah I
love the dump John Barnes comment uh I
was saying oh have you got the call he
was like No And also if you've got the
call now you know it was only because no
one else wanted to do it which I thought
was actually
um yeah pretty accurate probably we'll
have more from Liz after the break when
we're going to be talking about the
other really really big story today this
week's budget
I welcome back now really big political
week coming up of course with the budget
on Wednesday and there is a lot of
nervousness about tax levels
particularly of course from conservative
back Ventures and one thing I was Keen
to ask the chancellor about uh was he of
course was the guy who pitched for a big
cut in cons on incorporation tax when he
was running for the leadership now he is
planning to have it overseen going up by
six percent so I asked him if he's gonna
be as radical as some of his previous
roles when he delivers Wednesday's
budget
when I was young I took the decision not
to get a well-paid job in the city but
to set up my own business and that was
the best decision I ever took and I
became Chancellor because I want to help
people like me who had Big Dreams for
the future and I have Big Dreams for the
future of our country as well yeah you
were a radical on tax when you ran for
the leadership when you were chair of
the health select committee you wanted
to transform the NHS and now it feels a
bit like you know you're running the
economy as if you're Jeremy from
accounts well I think you have to wait
and see what I say on Wednesday
but you know Jeremy the chancellor will
be responsible with public finances I
make absolutely no apology for that I
think families who want to know that
their money is safe need to know that
they have a responsible Chancellor
Jeremy Hunter talking to us a bit early
about the budget I mean it
I don't think he was best pleased with
the Germany from accounts uh comparison
but it does feel like it's going to be a
pretty steady is she goes budget I think
it is and I think there's a couple of
reasons for that firstly because that is
more and we've seen this already under
Rishi soon act that's more of his
political style he is a bit more you
know he wants to be seen as somebody
that gets into the detail of things he's
competent he wants to fix things he's
not a huge showman uh when you compare
him to somebody like Boris Johnson and I
think him and Jeremy Hunt have been
working together and that's how they see
this budget they want it to land in a
way that is
um basically a little bit boring and of
course you know we saw that budget under
Liz trust that was anything book boring
that is the thing that they want to
avoid at all costs so I think that's
what you'll see with this budget I did
think it was interesting to see what
some of his priorities were and you were
right to push him on tax because there's
a huge amount of pressure coming from
the conservative party to cut taxes I
don't think at the moment that faction
of the conservative party has enough
sway over the government and the
internal feeling within the party at the
moment is you need to way you had your
tax cuts they didn't work we're going to
take a different route we want to get
the public finances under control and I
think the power at the moment is with
the Prime Minister and the chancellor
and there's a feeling of letters do what
we want and um there's also a feeling
that tax cuts will come so they want to
wait until we get closer to a general
election to say look now we've studied
the public finances now we can be the
party of tax cuts but it's not the right
moment it's interesting to say there
that the power is with Rishi sunaka and
Jeremy Hunt rather than I guess the
faction to the right or the conservative
party has that changed because it felt
like you know a few weeks ago when we
were talking about the brexit deal
before that was cut unveiled that we
were talking about the precariousness of
Rishi cnx position do you think he
shored it off a bit more recently I
actually think he has showed it up a bit
more recently and I think that's to do
with a couple of things primarily
um what happened with the Northern
Ireland protocol
because I think there were huge
questions around Rishi suno particularly
as those negotiations were going on and
there was only a small group of people
involved it was felt that he was keeping
the brexiteers and the dup in the dark
and then suddenly this deal emerged
which showed that he had really
understood people's concerns from across
the party at the same time he'd gone to
Europe Charmed European leaders and got
a huge success huge concessions that his
predecessors could never have even
dreamed of and I think largely in the
conservative party there was a feeling
that he was really showing competence
and statesmanship that no one was really
expecting from him and at that moment it
felt that his party came under much more
control and I think that's what we're
seeing going forward we saw it's been
largely overshadowed by Gary lineker but
he went to visit president macron a
summit that hadn't been held for five
years that was quite successful lots of
concrete policies on the table there and
I think what you're seeing here is Rishi
sunak stamping his authority on his
party and alongside Jeremy Hunt I think
we'll see that with the budget as well
yeah I'm going to ask you a little bit
later what your thoughts are on the
budget but just in the meantime the
other area where the chancellor is
trying to show stability shall we say is
over the UK arm of Silicon Valley Bank
which has collapsed there's clearly a
lot of concern about this and about what
it means for small firms in the UK let's
listen to his answer
we will come forward with a solution
that helps those very very important
companies with things like payroll and
their their cash flow requirements but
we also want to put in place the longer
term solution so that their Futures are
secure and how quickly should we expect
to see this package well as I say we've
been working at PACE this only uh
started to happen on Friday we've been
working at PACE uh over the weekend
through the night and the Prime Minister
and I and the governor of the bank of
England are absolutely determined to do
everything we can to protect the future
of these very very important companies
Rachel Ruiz the shadow Chancellor also
adding her voice to those who say that
the look they need to come up with a
plan quickly and it was interesting I
thought to hear Philip Hammond as well
the former Chancellor saying that
basically what needs to happen is a bank
of England providing liquidity I.E cash
to some of the firms impacted by this
so lose Wednesday big day what are we
going to see in the budget then well I
think it became a little bit clearer and
we've seen a lot of as we do these days
a lot of the policies already trailed uh
in the newspapers but I think it was
quite clear from the way that Jeremy
Hunt was speaking today that his
priority is to solve some of the
problems in the UK's labor market and we
see that there are gaps all over the
place for various reasons some of it is
because of brexit long-term sick but
also over 50s dropping out of the labor
market and you simply cannot tackle
inflation and go for growth in the
economy unless you tackle these problems
and I think the way that Jamie hunt was
speaking about that today those will be
the measures that they are focusing on
so that's really what I expect to see
from the budget bit of an increase in
defense spending as well I didn't ask
him about it because look I hate these
budget interviews where you ask about
policies and they're just going to say
wait to the budget weights the budget
wait to the budget is frustrating for
everyone involved but it feels like that
is a scenario where they're going to get
a boost right I think so and I think for
a couple of reasons firstly because they
do have a bit more spending Headroom
than they were expecting as I said the
pressures on tax I don't think they're
huge at the moment so I think they can
hold off on those uh for a little bit
and I also think that the um the UK's
military capability has really been in
the spotlight particularly over Ukraine
because we've been offering support and
that has then raised questions about how
much support we can offer because of the
level of equipment and Staffing that we
have in the Army and and other aspects
of the military this is something
conservative MPS have been calling for
for a very long time to increase
spending in that area and so I think
that could be potentially a big win an
easy win I wouldn't be surprised if that
comes as well yeah we can have a look
definitely worth keeping iron as well
and the other interview that we had on
the program was with the s p leadership
hopeful Ash Regan and she's of course in
me appearing in the Big Sky News debate
on Monday night and hosted by Beth Rigby
so that's definitely one to set your
alarms for because I think it'd be
fascinating to see the three of them go
head to head it's been a really fiery
campaign so far and actually I thought
um ashreaking did exactly the same thing
as well talking about how she thought
Nicola sturgeon's husband shouldn't have
any involvement he shouldn't be chief
executive while the campaign is going on
she really kind of went in there I
thought she really did look I mean this
is a it's a fascinating leadership
election to watch and I think the thing
that has really come across very
strongly to me is that Nicholas sturgeon
at the top of that party was holding a
lot of different factions together and
this is sometimes what you see in
leaders that are have a huge amount of
influence on a particular party they
leave and suddenly all of the cracks uh
yeah and that's what you're seeing
seeing going on at the moment I think
the challenge for the SMP will be after
this leadership contest has finished to
actually put the party back together and
to uh to mend itself after what it will
it be a period of very damaging
infighting actually it's such a change
isn't it because we've had this period
of complete s p dominance and Nicholas
sturgeon who has polled very well she's
been a popular leader
um she's someone who's got a really high
profile and as you say these divisions
have been exposed we have three
candidates none of which have got the
approval ratings of Nicholas Sergeant do
you think this is going to transform you
know the political landscape in Scotland
look I think it certainly has the
possibility too because we've seen the
dominance of the SMP over such a long
period of time and I think that is
intrinsically linked to Nicholas
sturgeon and to predecessor of course
Alex salmon these you know very
dominant political figures they're
backing different candidates right or
even if not publicly we kind of know
that they are behind the scenes yeah
yeah and this is what has dominated
Scottish politics uh for so long and I
think look it's obvious from speaking to
the labor party they are selecting
candidates at the moment in Scotland and
suddenly all these candidates have come
out of nowhere they are really sensing
that they could be the ones uh that uh
that really benefit from what
potentially could be a difficult period
for the SMP but I think it all depends
on how they get to the end of this
contest and how they pick themselves
back up afterwards because there's still
a big uh um there's still a lot of
support within Scotland for the
independence movement so they just have
to make sure that they don't
um that this contest doesn't become too
vitriolic yeah as you say the s p is
still wildly popular most political
parties can only dream of having the
amount of poll ratings that they do I do
think it was interesting to talk about
Labor uh there was a an event recently
where kistama went to Scotland and all
the political journalists were like
tweeting the amazing uh breakfast buffet
spread that had been put on they were
like ah they're trying to butter us up
they know
they know which way the wind is blowing
it's it's
um it's not difficult to buy off
journalists with breakfast and other
Foods speaking of personal experience
um I just want to remind you of course
about the debate that's going to be on
Sky News tomorrow night the Scotland
leadership debate live from Edinburgh
that's going to be at 7 00 p.m and Beth
Rick Baptist can be joined by the three
candidates Kate Forbes Hamza Yusuf and
Ash Regan tomorrow night 7 P.M so
definitely one to uh look out for well
it's been a very busy program uh today
as we were just discussing with Liz you
know we really did think that it was all
going to be about the budget but there's
certainly been other issues elbowing
their way onto the news agenda
do you think the Carolina story is
starting to burn out or do you think
that actually it's got some way to go
um it seems to me to be
unresolved at the moment I think there
are
um there are more issues that will come
up uh I have to say I think uh the
handling of it has maybe added to the uh
the attention that has fallen on it but
I think what's what's quite clear at the
moment is that the balance of power
hangs with Gary lineker he has all of
the BBC staff including some incredibly
high profile people
um behind him and I think this will go
on uh the interesting thing would be if
it's a problem for the government
there we are the man with all the power
in his hands uh Gary lineker there we'll
see what happens well that is it from
this week's safety Ridge on Sunday uh
this morning do join us for the podcast
though I mean Liz are going to be giving
at some of our views on podcast plus you
can hear some of the best interviews
from the show as well should be
available around lunchtime
see you next Sunday in which time we'll
know what's been in